we stay stable not by resisting change
but by changing how do you adapt how do
you grow how do you evolve we are just
always in conversation with change you
have this Paradigm around having versus
being so explain that the more that we
can Define ourselves in our Pursuits in
ways of being then the less fragile we
are to change and this is really where
the rubber meets the road where the work
actually lives and breathes
I'm extremely proud to introduce you to
our newest brand partner on check out
their lineup of super comfortable sleek
and durable pieces for yourself at
on.com
great to see you Brad thank you for
coming out and doing this it's always a
pleasure to
probe your brain and the occasion for
this which is very exciting is this new
book you've got master of change which
you did a great job on I really enjoyed
it I'm looking forward to unpacking it
so maybe tell us a little bit about the
thesis of the book and then I want to
get into kind of what motivated you to
explore this specific topic yeah so the
thesis of the book
is that we tend to think of change as
something that happens to us or these
singular events when in reality we are
just always in conversation with change
and because we think of it as these
singular events we often relate to
change is something that happens to us
instead of something that we're in
conversation with and the kernel of the
idea I know you said you want to get
into it so I'm sure we will in more
detail
um early covid just article after
article with the headline when are
things going to get back to normal
and it struck me that back to normal is
probably never going to happen and
um then I did what I do which is I got
really curious and I started looking at
the literature on how we think about
change and realize these two competing
models of homeostasis and allostasis and
we spend a lot of time thinking about
homeostasis and that's kind of the um
the conventional prevailing model but
it's not necessarily the best fit one so
explain that that difference between
homeostasis and allostasis what is that
concept so homeostasis is this notion
that living systems create stability
and anytime that they are confronted
with change or disruption they try to
get back to that stability as swiftly as
possible so it describes a pattern of
order or stability and some sort of
disorder or change and then back to
order right and that was sort of the
prevailing
I don't know if theology is the right
word but kind of operating system for
how things work how biological systems
operate how ecosystems operate for a
long time that's right since the
mid-1800s a scientist named Walter
Cannon coined it and science was very
different in the mid-1800s I mean we're
talking like pre-vaccines germ theory of
disease yeah it stuck with us for a very
long time and it's really encroached
upon not just scientific or biological
change but how we think about so many
different changes including habit change
I mean if you Google homeostasis and
change you'll see like this is why
losing weight is hard this is why
starting a habit is hard this is why
stopping a bad habit is hard but then
about 20 years ago
researchers
reevaluated this model of homeostasis
and they said actually when you look at
really vital thriving systems
they don't follow this path of order
disorder order
yes systems want to be stable but that
stability is achieved somewhere new by
changing and allostasis is a process of
order disorder reorder and what's
fascinating is if you look at the
etymology of these words
homo means same and stasis means
standing so it's having the same
standing by being the same and aloe
means variable so allostasis is
literally translated into stability
through change and I think that it's
this beautiful double meaning where the
way that we're stable is by being able
to change to some extent so we stay
stable not by resisting change but by
changing extrapolating on that idea
you can't help but think about Evolution
like if it was order disorder order
there would be no Evolution it is only
through the reordering that you see the
adaptation really so what you're saying
basically is there's a status quo
there's an intervening set of
circumstances and then there's an
adaptation to those circumstances that
hopefully creates a new version of that
impermanent
homeostasis that's it yeah and evolution
is I think change on the grandest scale
that we know of and you see allostasis
playing out at the species level but
then you zoom in on an given individual
and you think about personal Evolution
or how we grow over the course of our
life and it's very much the same like
we're constantly somewhere in that cycle
of order disorder reorder even if you
lived in um in like a container that was
completely shielded from the elements
you're still aging so like there's no
escaping this site right for any of us
and this is my whole thing you know
obviously I'm somebody who thinks about
change a lot how do we transform
ourselves how do we grow and how do we
evolve and part of that mental equation
for me is internal how are we responding
to our environment and that's something
that you go into in depth in the book
but of course it's also about how we're
interfacing with our environment and I
think you know this served my whole
thing not that I invented this this
dates back millennia uh particularly in
eastern strains of thought but this idea
that we operate on a sort of twofold
delusion the first thing being that we
convince ourselves that most things are
are static that we are who we are uh the
world is the way that it is and this
presumption that things not only are
going to stay that way but that they
should stay that way and if they don't
there's something wrong right and then
the second thing is this delusion or
Illusion that we have any kind of
control over this right we do we do have
some level of control over how we
respond to these things and how we
behave and what comes out of our mouth
and the thoughts that we entertain Etc
but we really don't have any control
over the external world and what's
happening to us so if we want to be
adaptable and we want to be able to go
from order navigating through disorder
to reorder we have to disabuse ourselves
of this illusion that the world is
static on some level because not only is
change the natural state of everything
nothing is static ever from the
subatomic you know particles to the
universe right like every single thing
is constantly in motion and it's really
our job to kind of cultivate that
awareness and then direct the few
aspects of ourselves that we do have
domain over uh to the best of our
abilities to evolve you know in lockstep
with with this and I guess you've given
a term to this notion which is the
inescapability trigger so talk a little
bit about what that means yeah so that's
not my term this is um a term from the
behavioral scientist Dan Gilbert and the
inescapability trigger is when there is
an event that happens in our life or a
change that happens in our life
and instead of trying to problem solve
or make it go away or wonder if maybe in
the future things will shift we as we we
um we just accept it is completely
inescapable and then when we do that it
allows us to start thinking about
reorder instead of just being stuck in
disorder or even the old order so a
really prime example is somebody that is
in a job that they just don't like and
instead of
shifting to a new line of work or really
putting themselves out there and trying
to they Wonder well maybe I can do this
job crafting thing where I stay in the
same job but I try to make it better or
maybe I can report to a different boss
maybe I can work with different people
and at some point you have to ultimately
say like this job just sucks I don't
want to do this I don't want to show up
and do this every day and once you once
you accept that is inescapable then it
actually allows you to have the
potential to change I think another
example that you know as well as anyone
is this notion of hitting rock bottom
when you're suffering with a substance
use disorder or many mental illness
before you seek help and I think that
among many other things that bottoming
out is sort of the inescapability
trigger at play it's just like this is
it there is no escaping this what I am
doing to try to fix this or make it
better isn't working so I need to change
I need to do something else right I mean
I think of that as this equation and
where change occurs when the pain of
your current condition or situation the
suffering that you're experiencing as a
result of that outweighs the fear of
change and that fear of change is also a
form of suffering and these two things
are it's another conversation that's
happening or a tension between these two
things we've talked about this many
times I mean I'm I'm a very stubborn
person I need to kind of be in that in
that tension where uh change only
happens when the pain of my situation
outweighs I go you know I'm just kicking
and screaming into any kind of
adaptability or change what's
interesting about that I mean this is
obviously we're talking about changes
within ourselves those those are are
mostly or maybe you have a different
view on this
um
situations in which we're trying to
alter our own behavior and that may or
may not
be related directly to some externality
that we don't have control over but
the irony being of course that a better
choice is always available to us that we
we need not suffer uh in that regard in
order to make that change we can always
adapt our our Behavior but for some
reason we're we're kind of hardwired not
to I think it's because the disorder
period or disorientation undoing
whatever you want to call it it's really
scary and it can be quite
discombobulating so before you get to
reorder you've got to go through the
disorder you're very attached to the way
that you do things so that is a you know
a kind of resistance to change or
um just a a kind of refusal to
uh review things objectively and it's an
emotional thing too like a lot of the
tools that you go through and this
journey that you go on in this book
um is about tools and tactics and
practices and ways of thinking about you
know how you interface with the world
and how to respond rather than react Etc
but
in my own lived experience and in the
many people that I've talked to and that
I know
it's harder because
emotions are messy and we come with a
lifetime of experiences and traumas and
you know kind of neurological grooving
that that you know is the predicate for
how we behave and unraveling all of that
to create a healthier new pathway is not
only confusing but sometimes just every
fiber in your being is telling you that
that's the wrong thing to do that levels
up that level of resistance and makes
all of this a lot harder yeah it's not
easy
um I mean what you're describing is like
voluntary personal growth and
transformation right and um that's
really a hard process yeah and
especially if you try to do it alone or
you try to do it and you don't really
want to and you think you should I mean
this is something that you really have
to want to do and yet aging like there
is no escaping it so it is coming for
all of us like I said even if you lived
in like a plastic bubble completely
protected from the elementary Johnson
yeah you're still trying to control
every aspect of your life but you're
still aging
um so I do think like we have to be
comfortable with impermanence and
transformation
um or at least get comfortable with this
idea of it but I think it's also
important to note that we need not give
up all sense of agency or stability and
I think that a common trap that people
fall into is they think of it as these
two extremes so one extreme is
stubbornness rigidity
um resistance to change for all the
reasons that you just mentioned and
whether this is internal or external
change and then the other extreme is the
very Buddhist or Taoist let go be one
with the universe go with the flow and
there's a wide Chasm between those two
extremes and I think that we can still
have agency and control and if part of
our temperament is to be someone that is
stubborn
um or even a little bit rigid like you
can take that with you as you change
there's no need to necessarily surrender
all of it it's just about how do you
take those core traits and then apply
them flexibly instead of like apply
rigidity rigidly right to have a bit of
a non-dualistic view of these different
ways of being that
is another conversation that you can be
in with yourself yeah that's right we
talked about this a lot um the last time
that we spoke and it's just been such an
important tenet in my my thinking in
writing is when I catch myself in this
or that which I do because I grew up in
the west and I'm a linear thinker
studied economics
I often ask myself like is it really
this or that or is it this and that and
sometimes it's really this or that but
when it's this and that then there's all
kinds of degrees of freedom to have a
big toolkit and apply certain tools when
they're helpful and not when they're not
right what I would imagine that that the
balance of that equation if you grew up
in the west and particularly in the
United States is going to weigh heavily
on the side of individualism you know
your own kind of self Destiny and your
own personal Liberty and all of that
this sense of tremendous agency and a
empowered sense or maybe an outside
sense of how much you can control not
only yourself but the world around you
whereas Eastern obviously very different
but that's a whole new way of thinking
and being that's foreign to most people
who were raised in this part of the
world yeah that's right when I was doing
the research on cross-cultural
differences with how we relate to change
um
this fascinating occurrence which is I
guess not at all surprising given what
you just said but still when I heard it
it was really surprising so in the west
particularly in America we identify with
things like our Enneagram or our Big
Five personality traits
um our Myers-Briggs score and there's
validity these are like useful tools by
no means are they not but in the East
you talk about those things and people
laugh at you because they're like my
Enneagram number is going to be
completely different if I'm with Rich
versus my mother-in-law if I'm hungry
depending on how well I slept at age 30
versus age 20 and I think that it's back
to this non-dual thinking I mean I do
think that there are parts of us that
are um persistent and that sometimes we
wish weren't so but oftentimes it's what
makes us who we are too and like
learning how to be kind to ourselves and
work with those parts but I think yeah
in the west we over index on those and
not pay enough attention to everything
that's happening around us static
identity versus this multiplicity of of
identity entities or multiplicity of
personalities it reminds me of ifs
internal families and Richard Schwartz
this idea that we are the amalgam of of
many different people and those
different strains of ourselves show up
in different circumstances depending
upon you know what is demanded of us I
think that when it comes to Identity in
particular change is really challenging
and the extreme examples are you look at
an athlete that is forced to retire
because of injury or illness or even an
athlete that's not forced to retire that
just aging takes them out of their sport
uh you look at individuals and the
struggles that they often face upon
retirement or a Founder if their company
doesn't work out really high rates of
depression anxiety substance use
disorders
um addictive behaviors as well
and I think that it is such a risk for
everyone but particularly people that
like what they do to have your identity
become too closely fused with what you
do
particularly if that is the driving
force of your identity
and if there's not much else around it
well that's what most of us do so the
example that I like to use or the
metaphor of it I like to use is I think
it is really helpful
to think of your identity like a house
and within that house you want to have
some different rooms
and you might have the room of parent of
partner of creative of athlete of
employee
um you name it
it's okay to go spend all your time in
one room for a season of your life maybe
even a few right I mean a couple books
ago right I co-wrote the passion Paradox
it's literally in the subtitle like a
guide to going all in so it's okay you
don't have to balance your time across
all five of those rooms or six of those
rooms but I think it is just so
important to make sure that those other
rooms are available to you
so that when [__] hits the fan in the
room that you're in you can go step into
another room
and this isn't just my hypothesis in the
literature it's called self-complexity
and individuals that have higher levels
of self-complexity tend to be more
resilient to change right if you're so
all in on one thing and there's an end
point to it or there's an intervening
event that suddenly makes it no longer
possible for you to be that person or do
that thing it can be not only very
destabilizing but you know actually just
cataclysmic you see this with all manner
of you know athletes who don't make the
Olympics or they do make the Olympics
and then afterwards they've never
thought about who they are and they have
to go through this difficult
reimagination or disorder reorder
process as you would as you would phrase
it and that could be very difficult and
I've often thought well
what is the in the passion Paradox you
know obviously explores this but you
know what aspect of of that is
disposable if you're trying to pursue
Mastery at the highest level of elitism
whether it's Athletics or or anything
else like you do need a certain singular
all-encompassing focus in order to
maximize your potential at the cost of
everything else in your life sometimes
what say you Brad so I I say Niels
Vanderpool okay let's get into this
because I got a lot to say about this
yeah I know you you go into this but lay
it out so Niels Vanderpool is
um a phenomenal speed skater he's the
best in the world he won the gold medal
at the 5K and the 10K the most recent
Winter Olympics he also set a world
record and Niels Vanderpool
following his Olympics he released
um this 67 page maybe it's 69 I don't
want to split Pages 62-page PDF and it
was
in theory a guide to how he trained and
it was a lot of specific workouts and
how he trained but it was also this just
wonderful individual philosophy of
approaching Mastery and excellence in
sport at the highest level
and Niels wrote about how when he was a
little bit younger he did just what you
said he completely identified with the
sport with speed skating his entire
social life his
um even like spiritual life it was all
just in the oval in the speed skating
ring and in the build-up to this
Olympics he shifted
and he took two full days off a week and
during those two days
he was as normal of a person as he could
tolerate being so he mentions that he
went out for beer with his friends he
ate pizza if someone wanted to go on a
hike he didn't say oh I'm not going to
hike because I'm supposed to be in my
Norma Tech boots all day I'm gonna go
hike
and
for a speed skater at this level to take
two days a week completely away from the
sport was relatively unheard of now I'm
sure we'll get into it he had this 5-2
training program so the five days he was
training all he was doing training
interject a little bit here this 62-page
PDF how to skate a 10K and also a 5k
which is kind of like the subtitle to
the whole thing
on its face is this training manual but
on another level it's also sort of a
Manifesto and it has this very
thorough-esque kind of Walden Pond
philosophical flare to
um to the way that he writes and when he
published this thing the whole endurance
Community went bananas and I I know in
your book you say like everybody's like
texting you or emailing you you got to
read this everyone's chatting about this
and this is something that's been
discussed on this podcast before and
when I did my podcast with Gordo Byrne
we went deep on it and he adopted the
5-2 method
um I love Gordo by the way yeah he's a
great guy uh he's great and so there's a
certain kind of philosophy around the
5-2 where you're getting a little bit
extra rest so that you can bounce back
and train harder but just for contacts
so we're on the same page here in terms
of like this guy's training output
because it is absolutely insane this is
a guy who is who is uh like during those
five day periods he's on his bike like
he just created the world's large
largest aerobic base he's on his bike
for like six or seven hours a day and
not just going like it's his Zone too
but everyone thinks of zone two is kind
of like your easy I mean he's going zone
two at 250 Watts like for seven hours
which for him probably isn't that hard
but this is still like quite a bit of
output so he's putting in like 33 hours
of training in five days and then he
gets those two days of rest but he also
would do like five straight threshold
workouts and you know he would set these
intermediate goals for motivation like
running 100K ultra marathon in the
middle of his training like his output
is bananas and that's why he's the
world's best so I think a lot of people
read that and were just astonished at
the the amount that this guy was
training and they were curious about the
5-2 method but what you're getting at is
is kind of the between the lines subtext
of this whole thing which is that it was
motivated out of a desire to to expand
his concept of who he was and his
identity so that he could Embrace his
training from a more holistic point of
view and enjoy his life and take life as
you know life comes as opposed to being
so overly invested in the results
especially when you're going for the
Olympics because it's literally like one
day if you have an off day and he talks
about that like you're you're [__]
right so what does that mean and who are
you if you get sick that day yeah and
and it's not like my reading between the
subtext I guess it is a little but he he
says as much he says that having a life
outside of speed skating allowed me to
skate without fear because if [__] hit
the fan then he still has this other
life outside of speed skating so I'm not
here to say like his training was well
balanced or anything like that I can't
comment on it he's clearly a freak he's
the best in the world genetically
training wise phenomenal but what is
fascinating to me is how intentional he
was about ensuring that there were other
elements to who Niels Vanderpool was
even in the build up to the Olympics and
then sometimes as a writer you just get
lucky and like these stories have the
most poetic endings that you didn't even
know was going to happen so while I'm in
the process of writing the book and I'm
already like you know honed in on
Vanderpool to to explore this concept of
self-complexity and diversifying your
identity
he decides that he wants to give away
his gold medal to the daughter of
someone that has been jailed for writing
a book that the the Chinese regime felt
was um was not kosher so like the
ultimate shedding of identity as an
Olympian is like you work so hard you
win this medal and then you give this
medal away for a cause that is human
rights that now he says he wants to do
human rights work so I have no doubt
that Nils vanderpol was hyper focused on
speed skating like you have to be to
train 33 hours a week and he did
diversify his sense of self and have
these other rooms that he could go into
which made him that much less fragile
and I think it makes you better at your
primary craft right it it it because
there's an argument there is an argument
that that is what made him better and
and I think there's a certain well I
mean he's not the only example of that
like I'm thinking of Francois Den who's
somebody I interviewed who has a similar
kind of Life philosophy there's
something European about that like we
enjoy our life you know I'm gonna have a
glass of wine and I you know do other
things and I have kids and all of that
that allow you to go into your racing
with a level of of kind of perspective
on on what it means or you know maybe
even Courtney do Walter who has a very
happy-go-lucky you know it's like she's
killing it but I get the sense that if
she didn't win these races that she'd be
fine yeah and and we look at these
extremes so like another great extreme
example is um chalene Flanagan who's a
close friend who like very intentionally
saw that her career was winding down
loves cooking so partners with Elise
kopecky who's a chef and dietitian and
like gets really into cooking so that
she has an off ramp from running
professionally which is writing
cookbooks and being in the food scene
um but I also think that just for
Mortals it's really important so the
book I'm looking at that we're talking
about I obviously want to do really well
I wanted to hit all the lists I wanted
to sell all the copies
and yeah if it doesn't
it'll suck but I still have the dad room
I still have the husband room I still
have the athlete room
um I still have the neighborhood
community room
and I'm okay like I will be okay you
know maybe that maybe the sucky period
will be being really upset for a couple
of days instead of a couple of years and
I think that like that is the primary
risk regardless of your level at your
craft in your Pursuit but if that thing
is the thing
and there aren't other things available
then when things change it's going to be
really rough and you don't just see this
with work I mean think about how many
people just get destroyed when their
kids leave the house and they become
empty nesters I mean q Anon is like a
high proportion of empty nesters because
like your life is full you have kids now
there's emptiness oh my God I need
belonging I need a hole to fill it with
so I think any time we really care
deeply about something
that's a good cue or a good trigger to
make sure that there's other parts of it
Diversified just like diversify your
sense it's your financial portfolio
that's it like we need to diversify our
identity I mean more broadly it's really
a conversation around attachment and
non-attachment how attached are you to
the results of your labor in 12-step it
would be kind of referred to as
surrender which a lot of people
misinterpret as sort of giving up or
being let's say fair about your life
which it isn't it's just a more Eastern
notion of holding on more Loosely to the
externalities in other words the results
of of the things that you care about
because you don't have control over them
and if you can be right-sized about that
you don't even need like if you're if
you can be a total Jedi about that then
you don't even really need to diversify
because to diversify really is just to
apportion uh your your potential
disappointment across a number of
buckets and kind of you know play the
odds with that but if you're truly not
attached which doesn't mean you're not
working hard you can still be totally
devoted and and hold a vision for
yourself of achieving these things but
but be so grounded that when it doesn't
pan out like you're still cool right
like that's that's the real kind of
elite level I don't but I push back
against that notion because I don't
think you can not attach from your kids
at least I can't when my kids move out
it's gonna break my heart right I mean I
have I have two kids that are leaving uh
and you know shortly there's part of me
where I think this is awesome like I can
like do it I don't have to pick anyone
up or any of that and of course I'm
gonna miss them and I'm gonna you know
I'm gonna mourn what used to be but that
disorder is allowing my wife and I to
reorder in a new and interesting way
that is bringing us closer together it's
a new season it's inevitable but
as a parent who has kids that are older
than yours like you are on an insane
roller coaster for years and years and
years and that will never end that's
right it really puts you in deep
connection with your inability to kind
of control the external yeah but I but I
think that notion of non-attachment I
think is just such a lofty goal that is
is very hard for most people to
genuinely achieve I understand the
parenting thing sorry to interrupt but
I'm talking more about like you set a
goal like you have your book right like
and it's like you know how it does on
some level is a function of how hard
you're going to work to push it out
there sure but ultimately there's a lot
of things that are out of your control
and when it's all said and done and the
dust settles you're still you and it's a
New York Times bestseller or nobody buys
it or you know more likely somewhere in
you know in the middle of all of that
it's all what it is
um how are you you know anticipating how
you're going to show up for that
experience yeah and I think that what I
argue maybe we're saying the same thing
is that it's easier to be less attached
to the result if you've got other rooms
of your identity yeah because if I
really just pushed here and there was no
athlete Brad there was no neighbor Brad
because I was just working all the time
Dad Brad was minimized because I was
working all the time and then this
didn't get the result I wanted I'd have
a lot harder of a time not being
understand not being not attached so I
think that maybe not attachment allows
you to diversify your sense of self
easier I think that for my Western brain
that does like to hold things tight
diversifying your sense of self is like
the more pragmatic path to allow for
some of that non-attachment in in
personal Pursuits yeah
every athlete I know is going to tell
you that having the right gear is key to
Performance if what you're wearing is
poorly crafted it's just going to put
distance between you and those goals
you've set you owe it to yourself to
invest in the best and the best is on
I'm obsessed with the cloud Ultra right
on the trails and I just got the new
next-gen Cloud Stratus 3 for the road
I'm loving those but on also has this
incredible line of lightweight high
performance apparel that it's just
beyond anything I've previously donned
it's like this second to none Second
Skin I love to rock the sweat wicking
Ultra tee and the ultra shorts which
have this pocket right at the base of
the spine that perfectly anchors your
phone no jiggle I'm just so proud to
partner with on and I love their vision
for the future where their gear is
fossil free and engineered for
circularity
so check out their amazing lineup of
super comfortable sleek and durable
pieces for yourself at on.com
a close cousin of all of this is our
friend uh David Epstein's idea of range
right when you are kind of pursuing many
different Curiosities you become robust
as a result and even Elite performers
who have been reared across a
multiplicity of many disciplines end up
becoming Elite in their particular field
as a result of and not despite
spreading themselves across many things
as opposed to being entirely focused on
one thing but I'm curious about you also
you you have Terry Crews as an example
in this same kind of you know area of of
of topic that we're talking about and I
had a few questions about how you think
about that because that's a that's a
this is a guy who's excelled across a
variety of disciplines in different
seasons across his life so explain your
thinking when it comes to a guy like
that yeah I think that
um Terry Crews is another one of these
just phenomenal individuals
um and and also just like strikes me as
a really good person I really like Terry
and
Terry Crews had these parallel paths
running really from the time he was a
child of Art and Sport
and most people knew Terry Crews as like
the linebacker but he got a scholarship
to interlock an art school I grew up in
Michigan this was like the place that
all the artsy kids went
um and ultimately chose football and
pursued football and played in the NFL
and had a hell of a career but in the
locker room he would like draw portraits
of the other players like he never left
the art room and then when football
career ended because these careers are
very short for pro athletes
um he went through a period of disorder
right like he he was basically way
underemployed
um in really like sweeping floors you
know didn't know what he was going to do
next
um and now we know Terry Crew is not as
a football player but is an actor which
is in the Arts
um so he held on to both these parts of
his idea he's a Furniture designer yeah
artistic he's a creative yeah so I think
that I think that Terry Crews is a great
example and you know
Walt Whitman said it best we all contain
multitudes and I think it's so easy to
forget about that and to get caught up
in one element of ourselves and then our
world gets more narrow and more narrow
and more narrow and then when that thing
changes we're completely thrown off
kilter
um so there's all kinds of different
ways to think of your identity as fluid
or diverse there's what we're talking
about which is having different rooms to
your house there's this notion that we
touched on a little bit earlier which is
like you have an independent self
which is your agency your ability to
control things your ability to problem
solve and then you have an
interdependent self which is yourself in
systems so how you are with your family
how you are with your community how you
are with your organization and we also
have what ZEM Master tiknot Han calls
are conventional or historical selves
and our ultimate selves and our
conventional self it's the self that's
having this conversation with you it's
inside my skin and my skull
but my ultimate self like people are
going to listen to this and then they're
gonna hopefully change something someone
might read the book
um and and then pass it on to a friend
and like that is the self that kind of
is just one with the universe and not in
a spiritual woo sense although it can be
but like in a very pragmatic sense of
physics you know everything that we do
is connected to other people and I think
that in the west where we won't run into
problem with change particularly as it
relates to Identity as we cling on tight
so we think of ourselves as one room
unifocused we think of ourselves as
independent not interdependent and we
completely forget about our ultimate
self and we just think about our
historical self and as a result like a
lot of suffering when things change
because it's like our small ego self
also
Brad there is no past and there is no
future there is only this moment right
now and whatever potential it holds in
terms of how you choose to act in the
subsequent moment right so how much of
this
um or how much of of what you're
advocating and and speaking about can be
Consolidated or or really condensed down
to how Mindful and present we are in
every single moment as it arrives I mean
that's every book that has everything I
was just gonna say every book I've
written maybe every book I've read could
probably all be condensed to just like
be in the present moment as much as as
much as you can knowing that unless you
have achieved
Next Level Enlightenment or you're in an
environment where that's possible you
are going to be influenced by past
experiences
and you are also going to be often
influenced by thoughts of potential
futures
um there is a reason that most people
that reach Enlightenment do it in caves
or in monasteries where there is no real
communication with other people for
extended periods of time
because out in this world we adapted to
use our past to learn from and to inform
our present and we also adopted to be
able to look forward
um so living in the present moment is a
really powerful tool
but if you're going to exist in the
worlds in the modern world at least you
also need tools to deal with the fact
that we're not always going to be
present and that's okay
I'm thinking about
the extent to which in thinking about
past present future
Etc and you know how we can have this
non-dualistic perspective or hold these
two ideas lightly between the
conventional self and the ultimate self
or
um you know what the what the future may
hold and what the past is impulsing us
to do
it strikes me that it's crucial if
you're gonna navigate this journey as
consciously as possible that you have to
do an adequate amount of internal
excavation to kind of understand
yourself like what is the narrative that
you're walking around with that's
dictating your behaviors and is that
true let's really
um stress test that or let's you know
get into your past traumas and how
they're triggering unhelpful Behavior
patterns time and time again because
there's an unconscious kind of operating
system here that will persist without
that kind of work and so you can read
your book and you can do all these tools
but if you're not actually
Reckoning with all of that you're
unlikely to kind of claw out of whatever
Paradigm you're in and and start you
know reorganizing your life around a
better trajectory that's right I do
think that
um uh trap
is getting caught up in Excavating and
digging and just peeling back that onion
more and more
and at some point like it is what it is
back to the present moment and like
however you got here here you are in
understanding how you got here and
having narratives around that and stress
testing your narratives and choosing a
narrative that is most helpful
all really important but then at some
point you've got to meet the worlds
where you are and where the world is and
act yourself into who you want to be or
how you want to change so the way that I
have come to think about this is
we've all got whether we know it or not
we've all got these core values
and core values are guiding principles
that we really Aspire toward
um examples could be things like
creativity Health authenticity family
community so on
and
for each of our core values
we want to have like fairly concrete
definitions of what they mean to us
right this is like who we want to be how
we want to act ourselves you know in in
your words mood follows actionable what
are the actions that we want to take and
I think that they should align to these
core values that really make us who we
are and then our work is to take those
core values
and apply them really flexibly so that
when everything around us changes or
when we're going through internal change
we can use those core values as a map to
guide our actions and guide our
behaviors the metaphor that I like to
use is that of a river
so on the one hand you can think of
ourself as flowing like a river there's
the famous heraclitus quote you can't
step into the same river twice that's me
and you man like that's identity we are
always changing we're in this process of
becoming
but a river without its bank is just
random water
so the bank to our identity
we've got to have some kind of bank and
it can be past narratives or habitual
ways of acting which it often is for
people or we can be more intentional
about that bank and say these are the
values I really want to Aspire towards
here's how I'm going to act on them this
is going to be the bank of my identity
and this is going to be the part of me
that's really rugged over time that's
going to help Channel and direct the
process of becoming you have this idea
of rugged and flexible boundaries
another conversation that's happening
another non-dual uh you know kind of way
of of approaching your life
um that [__] with us as westerners like
we like our dualism you know what I mean
it's hard to like hold two ideas that
are in conflict with each other at the
same time and understand that they both
have value it's sort of like waves and
particles you know yeah
so you know what I mean like these two
things are true and and they are
happening and it's hard for us to
understand it but the more that we can
kind of get on board with that the
better error and more resilient we are
[Music]
when it comes to navigating these kind
of unforeseen circumstances that get
thrown in all of our directions all the
time that's right and we know this from
the greatest teacher of change there
ever has been and probably ever will be
which is back to evolution
so what makes a species survive for a
long time
two things the first is it has to have
these core elements or components that
make it what it is and if those things
changed it would be unrecognizable it
wouldn't be the same species so that's
the stability part that's the ruggedness
the stability but then it also has to
adapt and evolve and be super flexible
on how those core things manifest
and that's the flexibility and
evolutionary scientists they call this
having again back to this word
complexity high levels of complexity so
you want to have differentiation these
different parts but also integration
like these core values that make you who
you are and if you lose the core values
then yeah you might live forever but
you're no longer you like the species is
it's unrecognizable it is it's
completely a different species it has
evolved itself out of what it was but if
you're way too rigid about who you are
then when environmental change comes you
get selected out right and I think that
um again taking Evolution this like
change on a massive scale and then
zooming into ourselves is individuals I
think a lot of those same things hold
true because to go to someone and just
say you're completely fluid you're a
process
um that can be really scary I mean you
think about having truly no confines of
identity at least in the west they would
Define that as psychosis and that's not
a spot well unless you're unless you're
Sam Harris
of Consciousness but Sam Harris still
can get through an intersection
right so like he does have a historical
South like there is someone there that
says like up the lights red I gotta stop
and now it's green I have to go so I
think there's degrees of letting go of
um of like that more that that locus of
self
um but I think for most people certainly
for me
like the goal isn't to let go of that
the goal is to know when it's a useful
tool to lean into but know when I'm when
I'm clenching it a little bit too tight
to drill down a little bit uh more on
this idea of uh values and trying to
kind of uh create a situation in which
your your life and your decisions that
you're making cohere along a core set of
values that are important to you you
have this uh Paradigm around having
versus being so explain that yeah I'm
going to explain that and then I want to
take a moment to go back to values and
and thank you for something that I think
I thanked you for before
but I don't know if I've ever thanked
you in front of an audience and
hopefully tons of people
so but having versus being first
um Eric from one of my favorite
intellectuals uh ever uh late 1900s he
wrote this masterful book called to have
her to be in in it from defines having
is owning something and having a
relationship with it which is an eye it
relationship so like I am the subject it
is the object and then being is very
different being is a verb it is being in
conversation with that thing it is more
of an essential relationship to it and
what from argues and he's right is that
when you have you suffer a lot because
all the things that you have will
inevitably change
but when you're in a being relationship
with those things you suffer less
because you're fluid you're changing
with them and you're more accepting that
they're going to change because it's a
process and I think this happens all the
time in relationships like the worst way
to go into a relationship is to say like
I have this person I have my soul mate
and like they're not going to change
they're going to be the same and you
have a having relationship and then they
change and you completely freak out
instead of being in love with someone
um and I think this notion of having
versus being is is is beyond just
relationships it's so important because
the more that we can Define ourselves
and our Pursuits in ways of being then
the less fragile we are to change right
so anytime you have something that thing
is going to change or be taken away
um and then it's going to be brutal back
to the parenting example because I I'm
shocked at how soft having kids that are
slightly older is making me like I'm not
a baby person but Theo my oldest is now
um almost six
and um I'm just madly in love with him
it's crazy and I have to constantly
remind myself like I don't have a kid
like I'm being his dad and and being his
partner in life and a friend and it'll
still be terrible when he leaves I mean
I hope he leaves it'll be good for him
but thinking about it in this context of
being in relation with him instead of
having a child that mindset shift has
already been very helpful for me well
having also implies attachment yeah
right and I'm trying to think of
a caveat to this and the only one that I
can really come up with is a situation
in which somebody has a desire for some
material thing and because of that
attachment that person is driven to make
changes in their life in order to
accumulate that thing whether it's a car
or a job or a house or pick the right
thing yeah and and and and that could be
a motivator yeah for personal change
that could for sure that could turn you
into a better person again this is a
western Paradigm being being the Eastern
Paradigm
um obviously it's the hard work leading
up to that in the anticipation of
getting the thing that is the real
driver and teacher that Journey when you
actually get it then you are
disappointed because you realize you're
the same person whatever and then you're
in for you know a bit of a reckoning and
a being a being way of being
um is
a completely different way of
interfacing with the material world in
which
those externalities those material
things are not
it's not that they're unimportant but
they're not defining I guess that's
right is that an accurate way of how you
think about that yeah and and things for
sure but also even our attributes
so like having a skill
versus being an athlete that's
interesting yeah because like you have a
skill well that skill is going to change
as you age whereas being an athlete you
can Define so much more broadly
um I think of Ambi burfoot the Boston
marathon runner that is like shuffling
but still out there running because you
know he's a runner like he's into being
a runner but if he had a having
relationship with the sport where he had
to go fast you wouldn't be doing anymore
or he'd be doing it begrudgingly
um so I think it's it's the clearest
example and the simplest example is when
it comes to things but I think even how
we relate to activities in our lives uh
trying to be in being mode not having
mode goes a long way and then to your
point about sometimes wanting to have
something
um can be the the impetus or the
Catalyst for change
it's just about picking the right things
it's like there's nothing wrong with
wanting to climb to the top of a
mountain and get on the summit it's just
important to pick the right mountains
and to understand uh light Watkins was
on the show recently and he said
something along the lines of
uh you know the happiness that you'll
experience when you Summit Mountain X
Everest whatever it is is the happiness
that you bring with you yeah right so
there's the anticipation or the
expectation that you will be altered
through the achievement of something or
the uh you know the accumulation of some
possession or job or what have you but
you are who you are yep and the more you
can inhabit that notion of being you you
will sidestep the disappointment of that
you know sort of Revelation yeah Robert
persig is that in the Art of Motorcycle
Maintenance
um writes that there's no Xenon
mountaintops uh the only Zen up there is
the Zen that you bring up there right
yeah I guess that maybe that's where
light got it from it's such a beautiful
way to put it so back to values in in
evolution because
um I think this is really important in
personal Evolution and we're talking
about it in a fairly conceptual way and
I want to make it real and I want to
give you like a very public moment of of
thanks I'm gonna get uncomfortable so
that's fine by the way you still haven't
answered my first question what was your
first question why did you write this
book but go oh we'll get to that okay so
um
let's see this would have been like 2017
2018 we talked about it quite a bit last
time I was on the show so we don't need
to rehash it but I got really sick with
obsessive compulsive disorder in
secondary depression and
Peak Performance my first book literally
[__] called Peak Performance is out
in the world and it is crushing that
book is selling all the copies and I am
in a really deep dark debilitated whole
I start to get better because when I was
in the hole I couldn't think about doing
anything other than just surviving
in about six or seven months into that
process
I confront this huge cognitive
dissonance in tension
which is out in the world
people see me as the author of Peak
Performance and like this you know
national International expert on
performance
in internally I'm suffering and there's
a six month period where like I really
couldn't leave my house like it was
really really bad
and still wasn't on the other side of it
so I was like quite scared that I was
never going to get to the other side but
I had enough capacity to like at least
think about things other than survival
and
the cognitive dissonance that I felt
having that public view of me and what I
was internally going through was just
like way too much
and I asked myself like what are my
values and at the time I didn't know I
was in full disorder mode I like could
completely come apart
so who do I really look up to
and I look up to you
and why do I look up to you authenticity
it's like all right like clearly I value
authenticity and not the performative
kind but like real authenticity
so I have two options
I either stop writing because any
writing that I do I'm not being
authentic to my experience and like what
I want to share or
[__] write about this
and that was so scary not necessarily
because I thought that people were going
to think less of me oh this is still
some years ago like mental health was
still somewhat more stigmatized you know
every year it feels like we come a long
way but I was just scared that like I
wasn't even on the other side of it I
was like kind of writing about a really
shitty experience from the [__]
um but that's like that is the value of
authenticity
so I wrote the piece and that piece led
me to sell the book that I wrote like
that piece set my career on a completely
different trajectory I'm no longer just
interested in Peak Performance I still
care about it
um but like at a time when my River felt
like it was exploding I had to have some
kind of guardrails like something that
made me who I am
and it was searching for those values so
like seriously a sincere moment of thank
you because one way they teach an
acceptance and commitment therapy if you
don't know what your values are it's to
look to people that you admire and then
ask yourself what do you admire about
those people and then that's probably a
value for you to Aspire towards
and then you just act on it even if it's
scary even if you don't really want to
um you just you you act on it and then
that becomes your Rudder that lets you
cling on to some sense of identity if
this is who I am so thank you for that
yeah
um beautiful thing I mean thank you for
saying that I don't you know I just
again I get really uncomfortable with
this kind of stuff but you know I
appreciate you
um saying that that means a lot man and
as you were sharing that and this this
kind of evolution of who you are and
what your identity is you know parent
athlete author podcaster Peak
Performance guy coach Etc and as you
mature
being able to
like loosen your grip on the reins of
the subject matter that is speaking to
you right like okay you you you're the
Peak Performance guy you can stay in
that lane forever but ultimately
growth and maturity is demanding more of
you and it's a question of whether
you're going to kind of heed that or
stay in that safe Lane because you're
like well this is what works and this is
what people want to hear from me and
everything else is really scary but
ultimately the value that you're able to
provide comes with
shouldering that responsibility
accepting it and kind of walking through
the fear of of doing something a little
bit different it's no different than a
band who you know basically is known for
a certain sound and puts out a new album
if you're an artist you're going to be
putting out new stuff and you have to be
unattached to the audience's response to
that when you know they're looking for
the hits that you know they grew up with
or what have you and I've reflected a
lot
on that in my own life as somebody who's
going through a number of transitions
you know swimmer
uh lawyer you know then
sort of ultra athlete and and being very
conscious like when I was doing those
Ultra endurance events and then
ultimately writing about that and
Finding Ultra and then thinking about
like what is my vocation going to be and
how am I going to support my kids and
where can I hang my hat where there's
some degree of longevity that I can bake
into whatever it is I'm doing realizing
like well being the vegan Ultra
endurance athlete like I was already 45
at that yeah like this is not an
expiration date yeah so how do you adapt
how do you grow how do you evolve in the
podcast I think is a reflection of that
it started in one place it's something
very different now and
it's always been
a show with a wide lens to have
conversations with all different kinds
of people about different things but I I
think it did start from A View you know
kind of a narrower perspective of like
endurance athletes nutrition being very
Fitness focused and now it's it's it's
much broader than that right and I've
been able to kind of adapt and grow and
mature alongside that and step outside
of my comfort zone to talk to people
that scare me or intimidate me and then
to begin you know writing about other
things that aren't related to whatever
was going on in Finding Ultra and that's
that's what growing up is too you know
yeah that's what like being an adult is
yeah and being okay with
um
maybe changing your definition of
success to be even more internal because
like you know maybe you are more
successful if you're just the ultra
vegan guy and you just yeah I like I
know when I do the podcast like when I
have certain doctors on I know those are
going to be they're they're it's just
those are the ones are gonna work right
so I could just do that all day long but
that's boring okay you know like how
much more can I say about that I need to
constantly be following my own curiosity
in order to grow and that means I'm
going to have conversations and do
episodes with people that I know like
these are going to be big hits but this
is important to me and that is what's
authentic to my own interior experience
and and ultimately I think it creates
more long-term value for the library or
the Canon of what I'm trying to put out
there and and and as a reflection of of
who I am in the short term though it
might seem like ill-fated decisions yeah
I think that's right well they're
ill-fated decisions against uh external
metric of downloads or people talking
about it not in accordance with my own
values internal barometer exactly and
that's that's it I mean I think values
are an internal dashboard so we have all
these external dashboards that we can
pay a lot of attention to and we can let
them make our decisions for us or we can
have an internal dashboard and measure
ourselves up against that and I think
that true success and fulfillment is
when you use your internal dashboard
more than your external dashboard and
I've gotten a lot better at that like I
I don't pay attention to metrics and all
that kind of stuff nearly as much as I
used to I'm not perfect at that but I'm
happier when I'm detached from all of
that but I was wondering like if I hired
you as my coach like what are you going
to tell me to do like what's what's
going to happen Brad where where are my
blind spots it depends yeah
um we'd have to we'd have to I'd get
we'd have to flip the script maybe we
should do an episode where I just like
have a coaching session with you yeah
that would be fun
um but yeah I mean the the honest answer
is I don't know I mean you'd have to
tell me a lot about where you're feeling
pain points and where you're struggling
um to to get into a conversation because
there is no there's no Plug and Play to
Excellence it's like meeting someone
where they are with what they're going
through and um and then peeling back the
onion like we talked about but
eventually saying all right like we've
we've peeled enough and now it's time to
um to do the work I was talking to my
colleague Chris this morning about
coaching and it's really interesting
that as a coach and is a client the
sessions that are really memorable are
where you diagnose the problem
so someone comes in and they've got an
issue and they're not really sure like
where it's stemming from and then you
finally find the problem you know so
pretend that like someone's face hurts
this this is not what a coach does is
what a physician does but same kind of
thing so someone's face hurts and it's
like Global and they're tired all the
time and they start having a fever and
you don't know what's going on and then
you finally locate like there's a little
abscess under the molar and it's like
Breakthrough so those are the best
coaching sessions like you know what why
am I feeling imposter syndrome
um why can't I relate to my teammates
like I want to why is nothing ever
enough and the Breakthrough happens it
was a way that you related to your
parents or a prior job or even like a
best friend that you're still constantly
comparing yourself to and that's like
finding the little abscess under the
molar but then for the next six months
you got to show up and brush your
[__] teeth and like that's what the
coaching is right so the Breakthrough
session is like the intellectual you
know like this is awesome but the
illusion is the work that is that no the
inside is not like so in in in 12 step
they say uh self-awareness will Avail
you nothing it's right oh now I know I'm
this and you think that you've solved
the problem no you've just identified it
yeah yeah and and the Insight is again
like that's what's sexy and that's
what's interesting and that's what then
you go home and you tell your your
partner about or your friends but then
it's like all right we found the abscess
but like now you got to brush your teeth
so what does brushing your teeth look
like and that is very much more in the
realm of behavioral activation just show
up and like brush your teeth and
sometimes it's boring to brush your
teeth it's sucky that's a good social
media post to brush your teeth it
doesn't really track on right but but if
you want to get rid of that abscess you
got to brush your teeth and I think the
same thing applies to to all changes so
why did I write the book because I don't
want to completely evade you
um
I think the first reason and foremost is
I try to write the books that I think I
need because I want to go on this
intellectual experience of trying to
learn about something that um will help
me
and in the five years prior to the book
I had significant Life Changes
um in a pretty intensifying manner maybe
it's just getting towards middle age but
it became a father twice moved across
the country stopped doing any contract
work and truly just went on it as my own
as a writer and a coach had major
orthopedic surgery that ended my
Endurance Sports career
um
became estranged from family members
that I was once very close with that was
quite painful
published my first solo book
all kinds of massive changes and like
you I like stability and this was
challenging for me and I didn't feel
like I had a great model or mindset for
how to approach all of this
and then the pandemic happens which is
change that we all faced on this like
huge societal scale and as I mentioned
earlier I keep seeing these articles
about when are we going to go back to
normal
and I think it occurred to me that in my
own life with some of these changes I'm
like when are things just going to get
back to normal that's what I'm like no
no like I'm thinking about this all
wrong and I literally remember Googling
why do we think of getting back to
normal with change and then like you
know six clicks later this is before you
could just ask Ai and it would give you
an answer I found myself at Walter
cannon in homeostasis and that was the
the kernel of the the exploration yeah
yeah that's cool
um
I think these periods of disorder that
visit all of us it doesn't matter how
rich or healthy or you know how
successful somebody is you don't get out
of life alive and and and everybody has
to deal with difficulties and loss and
death and pain and you know it comes in
different packages for everybody at
different times in our own case
um my family my wife and I during our
kind of dismantling financial and
everything it was a very confusing
protracted period of years it was like
seven years of confusion and
uncertainty and yes I like stability but
that
process taught me so much about how to
be flexible how to be neutral how to
cultivate a different level of elite
non-attachment and it allows you to be
present and it also requires or demands
of you a level of faith in order to
reframe what is occurring and look at it
as a lesson or an experience that is
going to inform your life at some point
when you get into that reordering phase
right it is the ultimate teacher as
painful as it is if you choose to
reflect upon it in that way and if it's
[__] hard you know and it's going to
be different for everybody but to the
extent that you can flip the script and
and look at it as
as an opportunity
um I think that these are the richest
experiences in terms of our own personal
Evolution growth development that
will transform one's life into something
that is so much better than they could
have imagined as they you know enter
into that reordering phase I mean that's
certainly been my experience and I
wouldn't wish it on anyone but I also
want everybody to have their version of
that but you have to like you said
there's no getting not alive yeah
um I think two things when you share
that uh came to mind for me the first is
the importance of having some expectancy
that this stuff's gonna happen
and having an expectation that like
disorder and change and disorientation
can feel really scary
um I think that so often especially in
America we have these Rosy glasses and
overly optimistic views of what life
should be even what change should be and
then when we get into the thick of it
we're completely thrown off guard it's
like running a marathon and expecting
mile 20 to be not so bad well you drop
out of the race when you get to mile 20
because you are completely thrown off
whereas if you expect mile 20 to suck
you get to mile 20 you're like all right
I'm here having a proper expectancy of
these disorder periods and how
challenging they can be and how
sometimes they do take not just days or
months but yours can help us remain
rugged and give us the fortitude
to work our way through those periods
because the brain is a prediction
machine and if the brain is just
predicting stability stability stability
and then suddenly there's chaos
and we don't update our motto we don't
update our predictions we don't update
our expectations then we're just going
to suffer but that level of expectation
has to be calibrated such that it's
healthy because the other end of that
spectrum is being a fear-based person
who's walking around you know just
waiting for everything to go to [__] all
the time and that can be a very toxic
person for sure to be or to have in your
life yeah so there's there's these two
relatively like polarizing extremes
between the Pollyanna toxically positive
person
and then the nihilist despair porn
person and you see both of these on
social media all the time either
everything is great always I just went
to the cafe met my friends had a great
you know veggie burger for lunch and
life is great or everything sucks look
at the polarization in our country this
that everything's just terrible
and in between those two extremes there
is this like enormous Valley that we can
all live in and I've been thinking more
about this and and I wrote about this a
little bit in the book that I think that
white people fall into both of those
extremes
is because they're lazy
so if you are
Pollyanna about everything and you bury
your head in the sand well then you
don't have to do anything everything's
perfect your life is perfect
person
yeah yeah
or like you're truly just like checked
out because like you know everything's
fine so I'm not going to engage with the
hard stuff
you don't have to do anything about it
whereas the despair porn and everything
sucks always people
it's like an intellectual version of
toxic positivity because then you also
don't have to do everything you're as
smart as me you would understand right
and everything and everything's hopeless
anyways so like I don't have to do
anything right and I think the work of a
mature adult is to be in the middle and
to say yeah like parts of me are broken
parts of this world are broken
but I I have to show up and even if it's
pissing in the ocean I need to piss my
piss because like otherwise what's the
point of any of this so in between toxic
positivity and despair is like the
ability to have some hope and to take
action and ideally to take meaningful
action uh Victor Frankel called this
tragic optimism right like to accept
there is suffering and tragedy that is
inherent to this human existence and
that the world that we live in is broken
in his time it was the Holocaust one of
the most broken maybe the most broken
things that Humanity has ever brought
upon itself
and yet even amidst all that suffering
we have to trudge forward with as much
of a positive attitude as we can so it's
not delusional optimism it's tragic
optimism Bruce Springsteen you know go
going from phenomenal quote to
phenomenal quote he talks about like
meeting the world on its terms without
giving up hope
mm-hmm the other example you have on
that point in the book is Brian
Stevenson you know somebody who's just
an extraordinary human who's devoted his
life to you know tackling very difficult
issues and nonetheless maintaining a
level of Hope and optimism I'm thinking
about Jane Goodall and her book of Hope
and talked about that on the podcast
um which is hard like it takes work it's
it's remaining hopeful in the face of
dire consequences and being mired in
work that has no end right there's a
certain
um regal-ness I think to that uh there's
something aspirational about people who
are able to to do that and that's why
part of why we look up to them I think
is
as uh you know examples of of you know
the better human spirit that resides
within all of us
um
but you said you know it's the middle
right like you're the middle guy right
like everything is like it's in the
middle well is it Brad I mean it's not
necessarily always like smack in the
middle but yeah I think like oftentimes
extremes just are not um
are not very useful or they're they're
useful in so far as like they're they're
they're Rudders that we can bounce
between
um but things really rarely are on
extremes I mean every once in a while
there it's a hard pill for me to swallow
Brad yeah I know I I hear you and and
that's just my Approach and like there
are other approach um a recent guest
that you had on
um who I've enjoyed watching his own
change in evolution I don't know him
personally as Tim Ferriss and I think he
said it in your episode multiple times
like he lives more on the extremes and
for his temperament and his approach
like that works out really well for him
whereas for me and a lot of the people
that I've worked with I think like those
extremes are helpful tools but we gotta
have other tools
um and yeah like you know maybe I am the
ultimate moderate maybe that's why I
don't have that many social media
followers you are you're you're
definitely like you always your default
is always like in the middle right
um and it's just interesting we're
friends and we've had many conversations
you know around this kind of top because
I am an extreme person and I've always
sort of been hard on myself for not
being you know more balanced at some
point just embracing this aspect of me
and trying to channel it in in healthier
ways than I have in the past but there
is something
it you know kind of inherent in how I'm
wired where I feel most alive when I'm
completely immersed in something and
giving it my all and it's difficult for
me to take on a project or get involved
in anything where I don't have that
opportunity because I don't feel like
it's not as fulfilling to me yeah but
I'm I agree with you I think on that so
I'm not that I am completely in
alignment with you on is like you know
going all in and finding things that
really light you up in that help you
achieve a flow state or Mastery and then
pursuing that all the way I I think that
that is a huge part of What Gives Life
Meaning in my language I call Excellence
like pursuing Excellence that is my Peak
Peak value excellence in love and you
could argue that they're the same thing
um so there I have no moderation I think
the the what you would argue I guess is
it's just looking the other way and
making sure like well if this doesn't
work work out like is there is there
somewhere for me to land and I
understand I think having that place to
land frees you up to do better because
you are not scared most people right and
and
and also calibrating that intensity
um
with the other values in your life to
make sure like it's so I think of it as
like a pendulum or you know today I'm
going you know I'm rowing my boat
towards this I can't row my boat towards
everything every day right and I'm not
somebody who can do lots of different
things in kind of gear shift in between
projects I have to like do one thing be
completely immersed in it and then I'm
like okay I did that and now I can go
over here my wife is very different
she's like you know there's like so many
pans and so many burners going all the
time and I'm like how do you function I
don't understand yeah and in my own life
I guess because I wanna maybe I'm
walking myself back from being the the
middle guy maybe it's just like with
these big Concepts but when I think
about it like
people will often tell me that I'm
pretty extreme because I just don't do
that much like I spend all my time
parenting reading and writing or
training I don't really do anything else
and I'm also like very
um keen on building Community where I
live but that often is just like sitting
on the porch
um because it's it's quasi in the South
now yeah but so I don't you and Ryan
holiday are going to get along great in
general Texas next week or tomorrow so
I don't have like I I don't have a lot
of balance I only have a couple big
rooms in my house
but I've seen enough people that only
have one room and and that's where they
get that's where they get dangerous I
think that where maybe I I am more you
know moderate or the middle guy is just
in the discourse
so not in how I live my life and not how
I encourage other people to live but in
the this or that the discourse that we
constantly hear you're either you know
happy or sad all these extremes I think
a lot of that is um it's just [__]
like we know that the algorithm you've
had countless wonderful guests on it
you've spoken about it yourself the
algorithm like serves up the polar
extremes because that's the hot take it
wants the contrarian perspective it
wants the new idea or you know
everything you ever thought about this
is wrong wrong and this is what you need
to do and that's what gets rewarded and
so a lot of content is created with that
in mind and the kind of more mature
nuanced approach it's in the middle or
it's complicated or actually like most
of what you previously thought is true
and maybe here's a little bit of an
improvement or a tweak on that yeah that
doesn't you know the internet doesn't
traffic in that to the extent that it
does when you're very direct and you're
looking right into camera and you're
saying they've lied to you and here's
the truth right yeah and I think that
with with performance and excellence in
in health and well-being and the topics
that I think about the most
um I like to think about it more as like
tools in a toolkit and you want to have
a lot of tools and a really big toolkit
but then you need to know which tools to
use when and that to me is like the the
way to be a craftsperson right like with
actual tools or metaphorical tools like
a good craftsperson that have a lot of
tools and they know how to use them and
I think bringing that to bear in
whatever Pursuits you have gives you the
best chance of of sustainable Excellence
I want to put a pit in that and come
back to it to talk a little bit about
some of the some of these tools
technology tools that people are using
now fitness trackers Etc sleep trackers
I think there's an interesting
discussion that we could we could have
about that but I don't want to get too
derailed right now I want to stay on on
the book and take it back a little bit
to this idea of um you know we were
talking about attachments close cousin
of that is expectations
um and you have some very interesting
things to say in the book about the
Neuroscience of expectation so walk me
through what goes on in our brains and
in our nervous systems when we create an
expectation
this is uh my favorite science in the
whole book so I'm I'm thrilled that you
asked me about this
our brains are prediction machines it's
the easiest way to think about it so our
brains are constantly
forecasting what's going to happen next
and shaping our reality based on that
forecast
and if they didn't do this getting
through life would be impossible
so when you're walking down the tarmac
to get to a plane if your brain couldn't
predict that you were about to step off
into a plane you'd be having 10 out of
10 Panic because you become I'm just
going to step off and fall so it's very
useful to have our brains as prediction
machines
however when our predictions are off
or when the world changes
around us and so far that what we
expected to happen no longer does it can
throw us for a real Loop because our
brain is expecting one thing it has a
prediction for one thing and then
something else happens
in the way to get through that is by
very quickly updating your expectations
and
the most interesting science around this
to me happens in pain science imagine
that you have two people okay one is a
soldier going to fight in a hot war on
the battlefield and the other is someone
at a grocery store
and both people get shot in the leg very
different reasons the soldier is in
battle and sadly there is fortunately
all too often there's a mass shooting
that happens in the grocery store so
both these two people get shot in the
leg same bullet
same level of Fitness same level of leg
strength same exact spot
we know that the soldier is going to
experience significantly less pain and
they're going to have a different
hormonal reaction to being shot so their
biology is going to be different even
though it's the same lag same gunshot
than the person in the store and that's
because the soldier has an expectancy
that they might be shot whereas the
person in the store doesn't so that's an
extreme example but we go through life
with our brains on our heads our
prediction machines constantly making
predictions for what's going to happen
next and every time there's a change
those predictions are proven wrong and
if we don't update as quickly as
possible we get cortisol maybe not to
the same level as getting shot certainly
not but the bigger the change the more
cortisol we get so being aware of it
this is how our brain operates and being
able to pause in those moments when our
expectations are not met or when things
change around us is really helpful to
Center us and then to bring us back into
the moment so that we can confront the
reality of it is that it is not as we
thought it would and confronting the
reality as it is is really a function of
responding rather than reacting and it
goes back to mindfulness and meditation
in order to be able to buy yourself that
little sliver of time in which you can
mentally process or emotionally process
what's happening
to a significant extent that would allow
you to then mindfully respond as opposed
to just impulsively react that's right
this is really where the rubber meets
the road you were talking about like
identifying the problem and then where
the work is like this is where the work
actually lives and Brees that's right
and so continuing on the Neuroscience
theme
another area of Neuroscience that is
really important to how we think about
change has to do with what researchers
call the seeking pathway in our brain
versus The Rage pathway in our brain
in the rage Pathway lights up when we're
raging when we're angry when we're
panicked when the amygdala this is the
amygdala when when our expectations are
not met
the seeking Pathway lights up when we
are working
on making the situation in front of us
better when we're taking action
it is a zero-sum game
tons of functional uh MRIs have been
done to show this this is the work of
yak I I if I mispronounce his name I'm
sorry Jacques ponskeep
um is the neuroscientist that identified
these Pathways there are seven in total
but the two we're talking about here are
region seeking so the region seeking
pathway cannot be turned on at the same
time and we know this in our day-to-day
life because you can't be really pissed
off in working to solve a problem at the
same time like it down regulates the
level of being pissed off so to me
responding instead of reacting is really
about activating our seeking pathway so
that our rage pathway diminishes and
then we can we can hopefully make
productive steps towards dealing with
whatever it is that we're confronting
and when we make that better choice and
repeat it we're activating that it's a
must open and what is it the dopamine
dopa allergic that's it uh you know
Pathways that that reinforce over time
those better behaviors and this is like
this is where psychology in a
neurobiology meet so a psychologist
would call this self-efficacy having
confidence that you can endure change
and and take productive action in
challenging situations in a
neuroscientist would say it's the
dopaminergic pathway and that's it the
more that we practice this the less
likely we are to default to the rage
pathway and we get into the seeking
pathway and it's just that it's a
practice
what is this concept of Zan chin and how
is that related to what you just talked
about zanshin is
um a term that comes out of a Keto
in Zan Shen is the continuing awareness
that a good Aikido practitioner
cultivates
so not just what's in front of them but
also what's around them what's behind
them what happened in the past what
might happen in the future
and zanchan runs in complete opposite to
something called Target fixation
which is when we're just so focused on
the thing in front of us that we
completely lose sight and sense of
anything that's happening context and
with Target fixation we also just Pummel
into the thing
because we're so fixated on it and this
actually happens so the research here is
with automobile accidents
um as well as motorcycle accidents and
what we find is that when drivers are
Uber focused on one thing trying not to
hit it they often end up running into it
you hear about crashes on the shoulder
this is the phenomenon at play you see a
two-car crash on the shoulder and
everyone's looking at it because they're
like oh my God crash on the shoulder and
when they get so focused on it they run
into it
um so
yes Target fixation can happen when
we're driving a car but trying to you
know use a poetic metaphor
this also happens throughout our life
like we can get so focused on these
things that we don't we lose sight of
everything that's happening around us
and even if we achieve it we just Pummel
right into it and we don't know how the
hell we got there and if you're so
focused on targets like you can just
Pummel into your death and kind of like
have missed the whole freaking ride or
if you're you're just feeding a certain
fear that something is going to happen
you're gonna you're gonna manifest that
for sure in some way in your life right
if you're just fixated on like worrying
about this one thing like chances are
that's probably going to show up for you
yeah and the more you can't transcend
that in the more that we can cultivate
this kind of continuing awareness or
this ability to see the whole field not
just the thing that we're looking toward
uh the better we feel and the better we
do because like alternative paths might
open up
and those might be better paths to
getting to where we want to go another
example because you know I pride myself
on really having these insights grounded
in research is um Summit fever with
mountain climbers it's the ultimate
Target fixation so Summit fever is this
colloquial term where climbers get so
fixated on summoning a mountain that
they make Reckless decisions to get
there and they get to the summit but
they never make it off the mountain they
die because they go when the weather
conditions are aggravated or when their
climbing window has passed but they
can't see any of that because they're so
focused on getting there so yeah they
get there but then they don't get down
so
um this is with any goal I mean that's a
dire one to have this happen to you but
it's an experience that the research
shows is is cross-disciplinary
where does your notion of
being adaptable to change learning how
to respond versus react all of these
themes that you're discussing in this
book where where do these intersect with
overlap with and and depart from
stoicism for example you're gonna go
talk to Ryan I'm sure he's going to ask
you this right like is this a stoic
approach or what is it about what you're
talking about that perhaps is a little
bit different than how pure stoic would
interpret
navigating change yeah so the the stoic
that I think wrote the most about this
is Epictetus
who has the dichotomy of control and
this is at the root of stoicism
don't worry about the things that you
can't control focus on the things that
you can
and that is great advice
there's not that much as to how to do
that I think
um in stoicism I think that the stoics
spent a lot of time I mean they're
philosophers like intellectualizing but
not necessarily a lot of time where the
rubber meets the road
I also think that stoicism Buddhism
taoism certain aspects of
judeo-christianity and Islam the Western
religions they all intersect like the
Serenity Prayer in Christianity is
basically Epictetus is dichotomy of
control in Buddhism it's the 10 000 joys
in the ten thousand Sorrows like shitty
things happen and good things happen
like these these these these themes come
up across Traditions both East and West
um how does this approach differ from
stoicism I think in the non-dual nature
of it stoicism is a western school of
thought it is very this or that there's
not as much room for holding on to two
competing ideas at the same time in
stoicism and I think the core of
navigating change is being able to hold
on to two ideas at the same time to be
as we talked about both rugged and
flexible
um not either or
you also think of it in the in the
context of these four P's right yeah
want me to go into this yeah what is all
that about of course every book's got to
have the four the four things with the
sit that start with the same letter yeah
I'm just giving you [__] yeah you know I
how many of those do I have in all of my
books I think this is the first time
okay I did it and I did it by accident
like I [__] you not the two piece I then
contrived so the two P's are the rage
pathway and when there's a change that
happens we panic and then we Pummel
ahead we don't want to do that that's
our default the four Ps activates the
seeking pathway and here we pause
we process what's happening
we make a plan and then we proceed very
similar to an ooda Loop or ooda loop
from um from like flight schools in
when we pause we create space to update
our expectations to see the situation
clearly for what it is to process it
and once we do that then like our rage
pathway is turned off then we can make a
plan we can use our prefrontal cortex
and only them proceed so people yourself
included might be like all right
intellectually that sounds great how do
how do I actually do this and what the
research shows really clearly is the
number one way to create that space is
to name what's happening
so psychologists call this effective
labeling so when there is a change and
you feel fear
instead of merging with the fear if you
name it and you say I'm feeling fear or
you say I'm feeling Panic or I'm feeling
scared or I'm feeling overwhelmed just
by naming it you separate a part of
yourself from the experience and then
that's your space like that's the
freedom to then process what's happening
make a plan and proceed is it important
to say I am feeling emotion X as opposed
to I am afraid yeah I'm identifying I'm
experiencing fear
um no one would say that um they are
rain right you're getting rained on it's
not going to be permanent it's something
that's happening so I'm experiencing
fear I'm experiencing pain I'm
experiencing pain they would say I'm
sweating
like if the the rain is an external
event but it's not being produced by
your own mind and body yeah but then you
could say I'm fearing right it's not you
wouldn't say I'm sweat
no you'd say I'm sweating I'm
experiencing a state of sweat no I'm
sweating like I'm sweating is fine like
I'm fearing but not but I think the
difference or even I mean we're
splitting here even if you say I'm
scared like
but I think that what the research shows
not I think this is what the research
shows is that the more particular we can
get the more space we create so I'm
scared versus I'm feeling a pit in my
stomach that is similar to what I have
felt in past depressive episodes
the degrees of freedom are a lot greater
with the latter in what is also very
fascinating to me is in another one of
these mergers between ancient wisdom and
modern science
um
the law of names goes back to Folklore
hundreds of years ago this notion that
once we have a name for something it
loses its power over us
goes back to the myth of Rumpelstiltskin
where the um the the protagonist's
daughter is kidnapped in the villains
say that you can't get the daughter back
unless they know my name and it has to
be my true name and spoiler alert the
true name is rumpelstilston and the
problem goes away so um what in folklore
is called like the law of names is now
just effective labeling um and I think
it's true like once you can name
something it loses its power over you it
doesn't lose I shouldn't say it doesn't
lose all of its power over you but then
it's no longer you like it's concrete
it's tangible it's something separate
from you it's something that you can
then
um as I said use the higher parts of our
evolved brain to deal with right
I was talking earlier about uh these
these periods of being dismantled or
disordered as as teachable moments or
opportunities that are Rife for quite a
bit of learning and growth
um you sort of contextualize this as as
extracting meaning right like how do you
find meaning through this process of
order disorder reorder and maybe it
would be illustrative for you to talk
about that in the context of your OCD
because you have a lot to say around the
you know the kind of temporality of
engaging with that process of trying to
find meaning yeah so I was gonna I'm
glad that you came back to this because
I would have forgot but earlier when you
were talking about
um viewing disorder and change is a an
opportunity for transformation and
growth I wanted to make sure that we go
to where we're going now
so I do firmly believe that viewing
change in disorder is an opportunity for
growth is the best mindset to have in
most circumstances Carol Dwight calls it
a growth mindset uh Kelly McGonagall
after her calls it a challenge response
to stress so when we Face challenges
when we face change saying all right I'm
going into disorder it's going to be
hard but I'm going to grow from this
works like 95 of the time
but there's a five percent of the time
where
having any expectation
or any hopes for an experience just gets
in the way and holds you back
so the worst thing for a clinically
depressed person to do is to say oh like
I'm experiencing depression but this is
going to make me more compassionate or
when I get to the other side of this
like I'm going to grow from this I'm
growing you know no you're not like
every moment of existence hurts
loss someone that's just lost a partner
God forbid a child maybe a parent the
worst thing to say to that person is why
don't you write down three things that
you're grateful for today
so there are these capital T traumas or
these periods of change where our only
job
ought to be getting through
and getting to the other side of those
and when we tell ourselves that we need
to grow from them or we need to view
them as a challenge or an opportunity
we often take a really shitty situation
and make it worse because not only are
we now in pain and suffering but now
we're not even doing what all the
self-help books tell us that we should
do which is grow from that experience so
in my own experience of OCD because
that's what you asked me about
I distinctly remember a session with my
therapist Brooke and this is maybe like
four months into things
and I remember telling her like I I
maybe I'll grow from this
um maybe I'll learn from this
and she said maybe but like maybe you
won't what if this just sucks
like sometimes the world in your brain
is cruel and random
and what if you don't have to grow from
this
and that shook me up I'm like oh well
then like then there's no point then
it's purposeless she's like so what what
if there is no purpose to this what if
like this is just suffering and it just
sucks
What If You released from any need for
this to be meaningful
and just get through it
and that was one of those like you know
find the abscess behind the molar
moments in a therapeutic process
a lot of what was holding me back in
that moment was trying to contrive
something out of this experience instead
of just letting it suck
and just being kind to myself and
realizing that sometimes things just
suck and they don't have to have any
meaning
now fast forward a year later and I
derived all kinds of meaning and growth
out of that experience like you I
wouldn't wish it on anyone but it
happened
so that was my own experience this is
long before I wrote the book so I go
into the research for writing the book
and that's in my mind because you know
the the first six chapters of the book
are very growth oriented and then I
thought back and I'm like but I don't
want to set people up for a trap that
they might walk into reading this book
which is like when the really shitty
stuff happens I don't want them to think
like I gotta do my four Ps so
you can read the book and you can apply
every single tool and for 95 of the
changes it's going to work but for the
five percent where it doesn't the actual
work is just releasing from all of it
and just focusing on getting through
in what researchers show is that when we
find gratitude and meaning and growth
after capital T traumas big changes it's
never in the process it's always on the
other side
so when we try to force that kind of
optimism on a shitty experience we get
in our own way when we give ourselves
permission to just let things suck when
we surrender to the experience then we
give ourselves a chance to get through
and only on the other side when we
reflect back do we find growth I'll say
one more thing because I'm a long-winded
answer there's a study I talk about from
University of Wisconsin with trauma
survivors and it's really interesting it
looks at the rate of PTSD versus
post-traumatic growth and what it shows
is that in the people that experience
post-traumatic growth versus PTSD they
have the same exact trajectory for the
first three months after their trauma so
they all look like they're headed
towards post-traumatic stress no one has
the trauma and it's like I'm going to
grow from this it's only at the three
month Mark do people start being able to
make any meeting out of a drama so what
is the differentiator between the person
who persists in their depression after a
trauma and the person who grows yeah I I
um I thought you might ask this and I
want to be real careful about how I
answer it because I'm not a psychiatrist
and I think that we often blame people
for their circumstances in these
situations when the real answer might
just be their inherited neurochemistry
so I think that that's the foremost
thing I know a lot of people that have
been through trauma that suffer from
PTSD that are strong [__]
and like could just be their
neurochemistry I think where it's not it
is perhaps people that do think that
like they immediately need to have
growth or meaning it's like this trap
it's Chinese finger trap like you put it
in and then you get stuck and then they
get stuck in this experience like I
can't even grow from it I can't find
meaning this must mean everything just
stinks stink stinks and it gets Tighter
and Tighter
um so I think that that that has
something to do with it
um and then it's also worth pointing out
that in the literature on this there are
certain capital T traumas where you
don't grow from them
so rape is an example
uh for many people war is an example
like there are certain things that
should just not happen to a human and
it's not the human's fault that they
didn't grow from it it is just something
that is truly senseless and cruel and
harmful although there are circumstances
in Which experiences such as that can
catalyze
um
growth in the form of finding purpose
and making sense out of that I'm
thinking of somebody who becomes an
activist as a way of reclaiming some
level of agency out of that victimhood
and becoming a voice for other people or
um you know endeavoring to you know
change the laws or whatever create
greater awareness around the thing that
happened to that person so it doesn't
happen to more people yeah and that is
that's the pathway out for sure but I I
just want to be careful to mention or to
be really explicit that
um I think that not everybody can do
that and sometimes it's situational but
sometimes it's just like purely the
experience that they went through was so
traumatizing or the combination of the
experience and their their own
neurochemistry
um but yeah the flip side of that is
people go through like the the worst
horrors of Horrors
and then when they're in it they give
themselves permission to just be in the
suck and get through it and then they do
get to the other side and as you said a
way to reclaim agency is to try to do
something productive about it but
certainly your point Rings true in that
when you're in the midst of an acute
experience your job is to
have the experience not try to extract
meaning out of it right like that's not
going to work like right you're
suffering or something horrible is
happening and you're just trying to
survive it your job is to survive it
right and to let go of any not to be
nihilistic about things right you know
your your therapist sounds a little bit
like we are nihilists no but I think Big
Lebowski but but
is an optimist a different lens for for
yeah I get it like you needed that right
yeah but I think because you can you can
spiral into depression by being a
nihilist yes so maybe maybe the the real
solution here is to remind yourself to
like hey I might grow from this
shouldn't say you're not going to grow
from this right she said maybe well
maybe you won't just who cares get
through it so maybe it's to say like I
might grow from this I don't know but I
don't have to and I don't have to do it
right now I just need to get to the
other side right and again we're talking
like bad clinical depression like these
are things when a growth mindset by
definition is not possible I do think
for 95 of changes it's really helpful to
go into them and say like this is a
period of disorder again let's like set
our expectations but like I think I'm
going to grow from this I think I'm
going to extract meaning and if that
works for you great I think that should
always be the default thing right but
you got to be able to put it down if
you're in a very intense situation and
you're like why don't I have a growth
mindset and how come I'm not optimistic
about that and about what's happening
and how come you know I can't I can't uh
extract meaning out of what you then
you're going to beat yourself up you're
going to get into this yeah
spiral yeah you can't you can't do that
you have to let go of all of that you
allow yourself to feel whatever's
happening you do the best that you can
and then slowly over time that meaning
will reveal itself to you or you because
humans are good at this pattern makers
whatever you're gonna attach them you're
gonna end up attaching some kind of
meaning to it that will be meaningful
and instructive for you to help your
brain and your body make sense of what
occurred that's right just like we have
physical immune systems we have
psychological immune systems and the job
of a physical immune system is when
there's something that's a threat to us
yeah it goes and blasts that threat our
psychological immune systems when
there's something that is threatening to
our Identity or to our trajectory our
expectations it takes that and it
integrates it and it makes it a part of
our identity but much like our physical
immune system the greater the harm the
longer it takes so if you get a small
cut yeah you can grow and make meaning
from that really fast you know I missed
my flight and I and I'm going to miss
the interview with you like that really
sucks I'm going to be down but like
whatever we'll get through it whereas
like something really terrible happens
expecting the same quick turnaround to
meaning and growth is a Fool's Aaron you
have to give your psychological immune
system sometime and you have to be
really patient with yourself uh the
research shows that when we are in the
midst of extreme changes
particularly when they're negative ones
time slows down like our experience of
time slows down and the reason for this
is because we evolved when under threat
to see things very very discreetly so
instead of living our life as this
continuous movie we start seeing things
frame by frame and things slow way down
and the reason that we know this is a
fascinating experiment where individuals
were hoisted up 150 200 feet in the sky
on this crazy ride called the scad that
has since gone out of business but
during the time of the study it was
operating and then they're basically
just dropped and this researcher David
Eagleman a neuroscientist talk about a
clever experimental design he had people
ride the scad and guess how long they
were falling for
and then he had those same people watch
others ride the scad and guess how long
they were falling for and what he found
is that when they were watching they
made an accurate guess they said you
know they're falling for about one
second but when they were on the ride
they experienced their fall as being
like three seconds so when we're when
we're falling you know physically or
metaphorically time slows down and this
is the biggest trap for people in
depression which is depression is like
the swamp and it becomes all-consuming
and it just feels like it is going to be
forever and that there is no way out in
days truly can feel like yours and that
is just your brain changing its
perception of time and there's not much
that you can do to speed it up but if
you know that if you have just the
littlest bit of consolation that hey
like even though this feels like forever
now when I look back on this period
five years from now 10 years from now 20
years from now it's not going to feel so
long
holding on to that little bit of Hope
can go such a long way
in thinking about the concepts that
recur throughout this book rugged
flexibility and embracing transients and
tragic optimism and having this fluid
sense of self and these uh you know
non-dualistic uh ideas around you know
who we are and how we interface with the
world
where is
tell me Brad
where's the spirituality where's the
where does faith enter this where is
there some level of uh you know
appreciation for devotion like is there
space for God in all of this like how do
you think about that I think so
um my interpretation is going to be
based on my own kind of spiritual
philosophy or system
so that's for readers to decide if
there's space for God or spirituality in
this for them
um for me
it really comes back to that distinction
between our historical or conventional
selves and our ultimate selves
so there's the self that even Sam Harris
has to decide if he's going to hit the
gas at a green light and get through
that intersection that is very confined
and ego driven
and that is not the spiritual self
but then there's the self that is
constantly connected to everything that
has a conversation or puts a book out in
the world or raises a child or that is a
first grade teacher for 20 years and if
you're just locked in to your book sales
or how your child's grades are or how
many students you graduated that gets
really tiring at least for me whereas if
you can remind yourself that you are
making an offering to the world and
whatever it is that you do and that's
going to have ripples that last forever
then to me that is the spiritual
component of all of this and any good
physicist would tell you that's also the
laws of physics
so like I'm back to your like middle
like I don't think it's you know either
spiritual or I think that like
physics is pretty pretty spiritual
discipline
um in what way like where is the
spirituality in physics and then on and
then in this sort of uh non-dual nature
of it the non-dual nature of it for sure
and just in the the the what we do has
Ripple effects that just go forever
um so to me that that's it more than
anything uh in in physics like you know
the butterfly effect
um and when you think of it that
esoterically yeah it might not feel very
spiritual but when you think of it as
hey I have this inheritance good and bad
for my ancestors
I'm going to pass this forward to my
children if you have them but to other
people in my life and that is kind of
like my position in the universe
then to me that is like a very for me
that's like that is a big part of my
spirituality I I've only had one what
I'd call like one spiritual breakthrough
moment and
um it happened at a time when I'd been
regularly meditating
and
um
I just distinctly remember
like
thoughts were truly just thoughts
sounds were truly just sounds
feelings were truly just feelings they
had nothing to do with me they were just
happening
and that was really scary and then I
called my meditation teacher and he's
like oh like that fear that's just your
ego waiting to die or not excuse me
that's just your ego being scared to die
like your ego doesn't want to die so
keep going
keep sitting thoughts are just thoughts
feelings are just feelings and then I
just pay attention to that fear and then
eventually
that fear that ego it all just was gone
and it was just groundless
and that moment happens maybe five years
ago I haven't had a moment like that
again I don't know if I ever will
but I remember that and just remembering
that that existed like in that moment
there was no life or death there was no
anything it just was
and then because I'm a mortal
you know how that moment ended because
I'm like [__] this is awesome and then
like then it's over right out of it so
whether whether it would stop meditating
whether it was a millisecond or two
minutes or you know I don't know how
long it lasted I truly can't tell you
um but unfortunate I had a good
meditation teacher you know you say that
jokingly but my meditation teacher said
like great now forget that that ever
happened hmm
and he didn't mean like actually forget
but he meant like don't cling to that
because like if if you try to get that
you're never going to get that again
um but it was that like it was that deep
knowing that I really am just like a
part of this huge dance
in that there is no I
but I still have to be able to get
through an intersection sure there's
something really beautiful and and
mystical about that and I think there is
uh there is mysticism and and plenty of
space for appreciating the unknown when
it comes to
um not just our relationship with
ourself but our relationship with the
world and and how we think about our own
growth and evolution I mean you're
talking about the conventional self and
the ultimate self what is the ultimate
self and what is you know from whence
you know comes your idea of that that
you know ultimate self and what are the
choices that you're making towards that
and what is driving you towards that and
and this perspective that that
um you know unforeseen events you know
the allostatic nature of the universe is
such that things are going to get thrown
in your path and you have a choice to
you know kind of look at them as
opportunities for growth and
tell yourself that that is happening for
me rather than to me and again I want to
be sensitive to you know it's like bad
things happen I'm not saying that
everything is you know
um
is there for you to grow you know like
there's tragedy all over the place but
in the everyday experience of life when
you're kind of thrown off track like if
you can look at it and say where's the
opportunity here how could I grow
through this how how can I make a
different choice that will move me
towards that ultimate self or at least a
little bit more in the direction of that
aspirational version of who I'd like to
be I think that's all spiritual and
magical and and mystical and you're not
going to find answers in physics or
necessarily in Psychology at least not
ones that are going to be satisfying and
reductive enough to help you kind of
have a very tactile sense of how
everything operates you know beyond
our five senses yeah that's right I
could not agree more
um the Buddha was purported to say that
my teachings aren't the moon but I can
point at the Moon
and I think that all the science and
psychology like it's all pointing at the
moon but it's not the thing itself and
it's also you know an intellectual cut
right and like who knows I'm open-minded
maybe we're making all the the wrong
cuts
um you know the new telescope like I'm
so utterly convinced that there's other
life out there that probably is
significantly more knowledgeable and
maybe makes better cuts and makes so
much more sense out of things we you
know just the difference between East
and West culture imagine like East and
West galaxies and I think like for me
part of spiritual practice is just being
open and curious to all of that I did
just catch myself because like the
reason I'm confident that there's other
life is because of science like just
probability Theory like of course
there's other life
um but I don't think they have to
necessarily be in opposition science and
spirituality
I'm going to resist the temptation to
turn this into a UFO podcast
I could like bite on that but that is so
not UFOs
um I don't know enough I haven't like
gone into that but I know a lot of smart
people have it's nuts that there was
that you know Hearing in front of
Congress it's like this is this is Fox
Mulder actually happening it's wild yeah
so what I will say is that
um in my own growth and I just have to
it's it's an area for me and
particularly for the version of me
that's on the internet
is I have to be really careful
I can be skeptical about things but I
never want to be cynical and that to me
is like my biggest blind spot right now
on the internet I think in real life
having conversations like you mentioned
like the internet's set up to do that
too but um your blind spot being that
from skepticism interview the sorry not
the interview the internet makes you
makes you it can make it can make me
cynical yeah and I never want to be
cynical I want to be skeptical of a lot
of things but I never want to be cynical
well talking about skepticism
um let's let's round this out with uh a
topic that I really want to get into
with you we talked about you being kind
of like this middle path guy you're the
grounded guy Etc
um I don't know how grounded well you
know you're kind of like well some of
this some of that not too much of
anything and I think maybe the first
time that we ever talked it was really
uh over this shared
sensibility around like the life hacking
movement and yeah you wrote the original
go article yeah and being like you know
sort of anti-hack yeah in our approach
to life and appreciating the journey and
you know hard things are hard Etc stop
taking shortcuts
um but I'm interested in your
perspective
on all of these tools that are now
available that are sort of in the in the
vein or the realm of biohacking you've
got like you know I'm wearing a whoop or
you know sleep trackers and you know
mattresses that can cool at night and
and you know help regulate your body
temperature and you know what else we
have you know there's lots of things
that I use like newcom or binaural beats
and I just bought this happy thing
that's like a magnetic thing goes under
my pillow it's supposed to help induce
like a deeper state of sleep
um and I've extracted tremendous amount
of value from these advances but I also
am conscious of
my attachment to them or my relationship
to them and I know this is something
you've talked about and and thought
about
um I I sort of see you as a guy who
who's out there kind of like railing
against all of this just go for a walk
and you know have a glass of wine with
your friends and forget about all this
[__] but I'll let you explain
your perspective on all of this so I'm
trying not to be like that's back to the
cynicism I don't want to be cynical so I
want to say I want to say three things
and I'm going to try to remember them
all okay I swear to God they just pop
into my brain so it really is how the
brain works
the first thing and I'm gonna forget
them so I'll probably say between two
and seven
um all right the first thing is that
the easiest way to determine whether or
not to use these tools is are they
helping you
so this is where I've softened up maybe
they're [__] for some people but if
they're helping someone else great you
should use the tool if you can afford it
and it's helping you use it
you also have to ask if it was helping
me six months ago is it still helping me
now or has it actually become the thing
that's getting in my way
and as long as you can try to honestly
answer that question great that's the
first big thing the second big thing
a trap that people get into is talk
about polarities for everything in our
life from sleep to Fitness to longevity
we are constantly bouncing between these
two poles of acceptance is the path to
happiness and problem solving is the
path to happiness
and the trap with these devices is that
we can get so Uber focused on problem
solving and optimizing that we never
accept our mortality we never accept
feeling tired or our life becomes
diminished because when our recovery
score is down we have a self-fulfilling
prophecy that we're not going to be able
to function that day or if our sleep
isn't perfect then we start beating
ourselves up and we get really nervous
and then we sleep worse the next day
there's a famous study that people that
use sleep trackers sleep worse than
people that don't this is that at play
so that's the other trap right that like
we don't want to just accept everything
that sucks if you're not sleeping well
you shouldn't just accept like hey I'm
going to be in sleep two hours a night
for the rest of my life that's not
healthy but we can get so caught up in
trying to fix everything but then that
becomes the problem then the third thing
putting my public health hat on is that
we know
from years and years and years of data
that really only five big things have a
measurable impact on Health and
Longevity in what we'll call well-being
and those things are really simple
the first and most important is not to
use tobacco products or if you do get
help quitting the second is to move your
body often to exercise
the third is to avoid Ultra processed
foods
it used to be to maintain a healthy body
weight the thinking on that has changed
now again I'm putting on my public
health hat where researchers look at is
levels of body fatness so you want to
have good lean body mass
next you want to have lots of community
and then the last thing is that if you
are going to drink it all you want to
drink in extreme moderation and I was on
Derek Thompson's podcast who loves wine
and people joke that like the last 20
minutes of that podcast was Derek trying
to like have me tell him that it's okay
to have wine with my friends and here's
what I'm going to say because I know
this is a topic that is obviously
important to you
I think that
sobriety is a great choice and there is
zero downside to sobriety I think that
if you are somebody that does not
experience any substance use issues and
you enjoy drinking there is nothing
wrong with having under five drinks a
week so long as they're not all at once
but that presupposes that one drink
doesn't lead to two doesn't lead to
three or you're drinking to run away
from something
the research right now shows that at
three to five drinks you start to see
the littlest dip in mortality rates and
morbidity so like health and under three
drinks it's basically a wash I think the
people that like hold up you know I'm
cutting alcohol I'm cutting caffeine I'm
doing cold plunges is like a moral
system almost like a Protestant religion
of like purification that kind of annoys
me and I think can be somewhat dangerous
but the flip side is if you are someone
that has it all struggled with substance
use you look around at the world and
you're like why the [__] are we just
selling poison and is poison such a part
of the culture and I'm equally
empathetic to that argument in me myself
I have like two drinks a month I'm very
fortunate that I don't have any sort of
dependency but I also don't drink
because I feel like [__] when I do
super interesting to hear you share that
I I I feel
I'm feeling lots of feels yeah you just
shared I think it's it's uh
it's interesting there's a weird
semi-ironic sort of inconsistency
between this thesis that you have of
embracing change while also this other
aspect of your personality that's sort
of stubbornly anti-change with respect
to a lot of these things with these
protocols and principles like the idea
that there's people on social media who
are doing like 30 day no drinking
challenges there's some peace inside of
you that is irked by that well it's
interesting I want to push back if it's
like virtue signaling or Bingo it's not
the change but it is it's a cool like in
the world of challenges this is not the
tide pod challenge no this is a great
this is a good challenge and that's what
I just said I have no problem with it I
think my challenge is when it is wrapped
up in this like performative virtue
signaling I understand and I'm also no
but you you said something
no I am I am open to these things
working I really am that's why I said
like use any of these tools if they help
you what I'm not open to is
pseudoscience junk which is what so much
of this is because so much of my
coaching practice is me unwinding
pseudoscience junk now if there is a
strong evidence base behind any of these
things so here's an example where I have
a really open mind is with psychedelics
now
I don't know what the outcome is going
to be my sense is that there will be a
really effective tool in the toolkit to
treat mental illness and they'll have
indications for certain people in
certain situations of certain
circumstances and they'll work very well
um that is very different though than
some of these other things that like
truly have no evidence base but this is
to be fair this is like where I need to
be careful
to remain skeptical and questioning but
not become
um
not become cynical yeah I think that I
mean first of all with respect to
alcohol it's pretty hard to make the
case that there's anything healthy about
drinking at all even one drink the only
argument being that it's a social
lubricant that puts you in a position to
be around friends and share some kind of
you know community-based experience but
if you can't have that without alcohol
then that's something you really need to
look into I completely agree and that's
what I said on this podcast with Derek
um Thompson which is like the the
problem isn't that people don't want to
drink the problem is that we feel that
we need alcohol to be a part of
gathering in community do whatever
coffee or tea and I I like the idea
particularly with
um younger people that there's a
pushback against this just acceptance of
alcohol being part of the culture and I
think that's a really cool shift so I
it's something I I definitely celebrate
but when I look at these devices you
know saunas Coldplay one more thing
before we move alcohol because it's
important we talk a lot about the opioid
epidemic but there's I think I wish man
I wish I could call my colleagues in
Michigan to double check the stat it's
either one or two years but there's only
one or two years where more people have
died from opioids than alcohol so like
I'm right there with you on alcohol I I
think it's that [__] crazy that it is
such a
um just an enormous part of the culture
however
I'm also not going to judge the person
that doesn't have a substance use issue
that can go to a brewery and have a beer
and enjoy it and get on with their life
and be totally fine right that's not me
yeah but but we're different but of
course that's not we have different
experiences I know I know
um when I think about
these uh technological breakthroughs
these devices whether it's a GPS watch
or or a whoop sleep tracker Etc
um I think about and I see
resistance to them out there because
I've gotten a lot of value out of them
yeah I think about like the pace clock
on the deck when I was a swimmer and the
guy who's saying what do you need a pace
clock for or like what do you why are
you using a stopwatch you know like yeah
these are just tools they're neutral
it's your relationship to them are they
helping you are they not and I could
tell you that you know getting in
anything that's connecting me to what my
body is doing and giving me uh
information how helps me make better
decisions and I can tell you that my
sleep has improved because I'm much more
connected to what's happening with my
HRV or what is my resting heart rate
what happens when I you know eat this
food or that food or at this time versus
that time in terms of my Sleep Quality
when you talked about the pillars like
it's sleep it's Fitness movement right
it's it's nutrition it's you know these
are like very basic things and I look at
these tools as just a way of giving you
information about what your body is
doing so that you can be more informed
about making better decisions that will
be beneficial I do agree that you can
get too caught up in scores and metrics
and things like that that become
predictive of behavior in an unhealthy
way
but
um I think what they do is like in a way
like here's the example I would give
as a swimmer
I would do let's say I'm doing a set of
10 times 100. on a certain interval as a
young person I wouldn't know when I was
coming in what the time what the pace
clock would say but by the time I was 18
or 19 or 20 I my I was so in tune with
my body I could tell you what the pace
clock said before I touched the wall and
I could tell you what my heart rate was
like you just you have that level of
deep integration with yourself but that
tool helped me make that connection and
I think these things are no different
and when I reflect upon where most
people are like I'm pretty in tune with
my body you are as well but there's a
lot of people who are walking around
they're just totally detached from their
body they don't even know what it's like
to feel good they don't know what their
heart you know any so these are really
powerful tools to get people more
engaged and emotionally connected to
what their body's doing where they go
wow I didn't realize that was happening
like oh I see that graph holy [__] like
yeah maybe I shouldn't drink a Big Gulp
right before I go to bed or whatever it
is so I'm I'm with you that's what I
mean that was my first principle right
like you ask yourself is this tool
helping me
and if it is then use it
um what you're describing uh in Talent
research we call the four levels of
competence
if you heard of this framework or no uh
no so the the first level is unconscious
incompetence in here you don't know that
you don't know what you're doing and no
tools are going to help you you need to
like read some books and get some
coaching then the next level is
conscious incompetence so this is when
you know that you don't know what you're
doing and here tools are really helpful
because they can help you course correct
like you know that I'm doing it wrong so
the tools can really help then the third
level is conscious competence so you
know that you know what you're doing
you're effortly thinking about what you
have to do this is you looking at that
pace clock and you're really competent
but you're very conscious of what you're
doing and then the fourth level is
unconscious competence and this is like
Excellence Mastery flow where you don't
need the pace clock you don't need any
of it so the tools help you as you said
get to that point and I think that's the
most assuming that the tools are
accurate and the feedback if the pace
clock is giving you the wrong numbers
then it's not very helpful but assuming
that the tools are accurate then they're
extremely helpful on a journey to
complete Mastery and even if you never
reach complete Mastery who cares like if
you're getting the eight hours of sleep
because whatever device you're using is
supporting you and doing that so long as
it's accurate then I can like
incontestably get behind that tool all
right you're on the record yeah I like
it yeah and but this is an area where I
think I've opened my mind a little
because I think I was like a little more
quick
um I don't know maybe a few years ago
but I also think the claims have kind of
moderated with what some of these tools
can and um and can't do well nothing's a
Panacea again they're tools they're
helpful right yeah and
um and I think you know it's sort of
when you make that connection like oh
when I feel like this it's because of
this and then that gets lodged in your
brain right and then the next thing oh
that's telling me this is happening when
I feel like that I'm gonna remember that
yeah you know and then you know it just
it's they're just little kind of like
bricks along the path I think yeah and I
mean and I I use tools in my own life
um maybe not to the same the same number
as you I mean I'm not like you know me
like you know I'm not like a biohacker
guy right like I'm not like Mr you know
you're not using it as like a free
it sounds like you are genuinely using
it because they help you which is the
best way to be in relation to these I
use a pedometer uh because as I started
strength training I wanted to make sure
that I'm like getting a lot of steps
just to get aerobic work during the day
um when I do aerobic training I use a
heart rate monitor because that's
helpful feedback I don't know my body
especially like my bigger strength
training body well enough to necessarily
stay where I need to be
um
do I use any other tools I think those
are the two that I use so to kind of
bring this to a conclusion Brad uh I
want to give you the opportunity to
share
um some of the tools which will be a bit
of a recap of what we've already talked
about but tools that you've arrived upon
through the research and the writing of
this book around developing rugged
flexibility and being kind of adaptable
to the changing world around us
so I'll break it down into mindset
identity and actions which is the
structure of the book
so on mindset it is shifting from a
homeostatic approach to change to an
allostatic approach to change so there's
no going back to order we're constantly
in the process of reordering ourselves
in holding this notion of being rugged
and flexible at the same time so we're
not sacrificing all agency in the midst
of change and saying we're just going to
go with the flow but we're also not
being so rigid that we're resisting
change and suffering as a result
having the right expectations and then
updating those expectations accordingly
remembering that our brain is a
prediction machine and when reality
doesn't match predictions we get thrown
for a loop so our work then
the four P's pause process plan proceed
create space to update our expectations
so that we can meet reality where it is
and then meeting reality where it is
accepting reality accepting change not
resisting it so that's what I would call
Rugged and flexible mindset
then when we talk about identity what
does it mean to have a rugged and
flexible identity I think this is about
conceiving of yourself is having
multiple rooms to your identity and it's
okay to go spend time in one room spend
a year spend a decade in one room really
pursuing Mastery just never leave the
other rooms behind you don't want to be
living in a a one-room house because
when that room changes makes you fragile
and then thinking of our identity is not
dually so we have a South that is right
here that goes through the intersection
that has this conversation and then we
have this ultimate this more spiritual
self that's connected to everything and
both of those things can be true at the
same time
and then when it gets to actions this is
about really activating our seeking
pathway not our rage pathway so that
when we are dancing with change when
we're in conversation with change we're
taking skillful productive actions that
align with our core values and um
finally and when you need it perhaps
most important is when you're doing all
of this and things still just suck and
you can't find any meaning you can't
find three things that you're grateful
for
seeking help because it sounds like
you're probably in a situation where you
need it and releasing from the idea that
you need to do anything other than
survive the experience not becoming
nihilistic about it but saying that hey
maybe I'll grow but maybe this is just
senseless pain but I'm not going to find
out until I'm on the other side of this
so right now my work is just getting to
the other side I love you buddy and you
did a great job with this book master of
change available everywhere that's right
hopefully at your favorite independent
bookstore Brad's going to be out talking
about it
and uh pick it up
thank you earliest opportunity easiest
way to track down Brad and get to know
him a little bit better where are you
showing up these days you're kind of a
little bit off Twitter you pivoted more
to Instagram but you kind of grew your
audience on Twitter right so
yeah that's been a change never let a
crisis go to waste I um
I didn't love the direction that Twitter
was heading about seven months ago so I
said like I'm gonna gonna build an
Instagram platform or at least try to
start from scratch so now that is the
place that I'm most active and it's just
my name at Brad stahlberg and that's
something I changed my mind on I thought
Instagram was by far the worst of all
the platforms and it is by far my
favorite platform
and it was like what are you doing you
were like so attached to just being a
Twitter guy yeah so you were right
that's cool and the growth equation and
the growth equation podcast I'll link up
all the links to all that stuff in the
show notes as usual thanks it's always
it's always a pleasure That's it man we
did it peace